and I see that it's liquor has been
jamming out a little bit I am curious
cuz you're a classical player so you're
used to playing in complete silence but
when you stream you listen with music do
you think it's more difficult for you or
the same no it's better with music
there's more rhythm it's like you get
into a flow like I I love I love playing
chess with music and I think certainly
in the future if chess ever becomes an
eSport and you're playing I think for
sure with headphones and everything
there's no reason that people can't
listen to music and I'd love to
alright let's let's watch the game it
started right yep it just started as you
finished that sentence so we got efore
be 5 9 f3 d6 we got a Philidor oh so
this could be a good opening it could
also be dangerous III don't know who's
been preparing slicker if you came up
with this earth Hans and even helped him
it's a very dangerous opening choice if
you don't know the exact move or though
because you're sacrificing your
development at the very start of the
game so I'm I'm actually kind of
concerned I'm hoping is something
something prepared here this could go
wrong very quickly if he doesn't know
the exact move order to answer your
question let's listen in on slicker and
see how he's thinking about this or
listen to his tunes that's okay to look
at you small Monica
if I go over here then here alright he's
surviving this so far I doesn't fit
silly it does seem like he's not
familiar with the opening though
oh you play d5 oh yeah so II five is now
under attack need to think I'm not
thinking obstruct yeah cool head but
again it's very early it's only one pond
I mean I think if he can bring his night
on develop all the champ I'm assuming
that he didn't get any coaching my
intuition as well because he's already
starting to think very early on and the
way he's talking about it seems like
he's not even sure if this is good or
not yeah weird but again just to think
who's that extra pond as you were
talking but if he can develop his pieces
and act so quickly then he's certainly
still in the game so yeah supports and
cakes upon very classical so now it's
absolutely critical critical that
slicker brings a night out oh right
because Queen h5 is now an option for
forsen because he didn't play Knight f6
and I mean if he plays g6 how hard do
you think it is to see that the knight
can take on g6 well the problem with
this position as I see it is that is
that forsen has been studying the lab me
again at least when I was showing him
some suffer very briefly I showed him
the Latvian gambit and so he's used this
idea with the knight in the Queen and
having to deal with this idea from the
other side so
because of that I think forsen is is
gonna see it in a second and he already
played the h5 so this this is brutal
this could be very very difficult right
because in the latvian when you push you
push the pawn next to king so white can
oftentimes capture pawn and move the
queen up say he sees it so he has been
he is familiar with this oh gosh
flicker getting a little bit destroyed
out of the opening here brutal brutal
brutal for you know I think forces is
one of these guys also most of the
streamers have done the last is on sugar
they've been very open with what they're
doing
I feel like forces one of these guys is
probably actually ushering been like
looking up opening openings and studying
because the quickness with which he's
played these moves indicates that he's
like familiar with the setup or the
pattern and also he just having a lot of
confidence so I feeling he's probably
actually looked at some openings or done
some research off stream as well because
he's crushing it he's she's absolutely
crushing it or as someone said in chat
forsen is pretending I mean that would
be a true 5 had moved just you know
sinking the rating pretending to be just
you know he's just no good at chess and
all this stuff yeah I mean that would be
a real 5 had moved
yeah then coming in as somebody who
seems like an underdog and the
championship brackets to win it all that
would be insane yeah exactly
I mean he's playing great like Queen g7
another pretty good move now Bishop g5
would be absolutely perfect
or he can castle and bring your rook in
as well I'm not sure we I mean I want to
see force and just play like very clean
nice moves here I want to see him prove
to me that he is he's a serious
contender that and to win this
tournament so I want to see him go
Bishop g5 he carves oh my gosh going for
it that's our board oh that's our board
oh he did it
oh yeah I need to go get a glass of wine
and just enjoy this game with some
classical music this is just beautiful
alright so what does he need to continue
doing here to impress you I mean I think
he's already much better he can trade
the Queens remove the Queen back with
very very nice Wow
did he play seriously clean chess from
forsen he's keeping the Queen on because
he is the one attacking he finds this
nice check that's also putting pressure
on the bishop even if black and defended
he can
the defender after he castles so pretty
impressive
this is very impressive stuff from
forsen he clearly did his homework Wow
well chat clip it and send it to force
and so that he can continue to stay
motivated to impress Hikaru yeah this I
mean I feel bad for slicker because this
is just sort of a very brutal kind of
man just a brutal opening game jeez yeah
that's true I guess I mean slicker
certainly needs more help on the opening
side because that's always the risk when
you're you know the slight underdog in
the game if you go out quickly in the
opening and you lose material there's no
chance you have to get out of it alive
right and that's why I think a lot of
okay but slicker finds Knight to d5
which is a very good move here because
white cannot capture night because the
king and Knight or pen so 95 is a very
good move I think really the only
question here remaining for force in
this game is which side to castle the
King on any did he Castle it's the King
slide yes Wow Wow we've seen a lot of
shocked Chicago and now we're seeing
proud Hikaru it's been happening less
often so enjoy the moment this is this
is I I removed the forest has played in
this game I really there's nothing
really bad I can say similar to what NIM
did although in nibs game he got the
advantage and it was very basic
straightforward opening principles
whereas in this game it's been been more
like good moves but they aren't moves
that are as obvious or as thematic so
that's why I feel like the moves in this
game have impressed me a little bit more
because NIMS was where they were they
were two Matic develop bring in center
push try to open the lines it felt very
very straight forward in a way that this
hasn't been so well just everyone saying
hold it in because as soon as I say that
like I've said before forsen does have
these moments where for like a mover to
he will accidentally like hang a queen
or something so let's not make let's see
let's see it force and can avoid that
that's the only weakness the major
weakness I've seen in his game so far
and now he's sitting and he's taking a
little bit of a think and this is
probably a good position to do that
because he's 1d material his opponents
king is in the center of the board so if
he can take some time now to come up
with a bit of a strategy then he'll be
able to play faster moving on
right and he's still six minutes so I
don't think time is really an issue at
this point so I really like what's going
on yeah and I saw his his mouse hovering
over his queen and yeah we're about to
bring a slicker fullscreen I think
there's some interesting thoughts going
on there but he has to retreat this
because now the Queen's not threat
anymore or the king kingdom gang
it's pretty silent five minutes this
month on you fast
do you know play hearthstone oh no
hearthstone has a specific time my nails
to the edge is he crushed free win oh
just a timing yeah yeah I got a little
bit distracted but 24 does make sense so
he moved his Queen away from the threat
and he's putting pressure towards e6
he's keeping the bishop defend it very
logical move here right I think he's
doing very well so far I think probably
okay so liquor has to be very careful
here not to lose this Knight he's got to
do something about his knight on the
square in the center so I I don't know I
I I'm very I think even though he's
using a lot of time I do like the way
forest is playing the only danger as I
see it is either he like blunders apiece
or he doesn't see a straight forward
plant so he uses too much time but in
general I think that forsen is doing
very well here right so in terms of what
slicker should try to do he's up on the
clock seven minutes to five he's playing
quickly which is what we want to see
soon he's gonna bring on his rook over
and can he can pseudo castle his King
but it is a little tough to see that but
if you can get his rook out and his King
to safety then I'll be feeling like he
does actually have comeback chances yeah
I think I mean I think it's certainly
possible based on the way the position
is very closed so even though White has
the extra rip for the night there aren't
open lines for the rooks there's only
this Uihlein but it's kind of closed
is so if forsen uses too much time
trying to work out a plan he could get
really low on the talk and something bad
could happen but he plays rookie one
very quickly a very solid move putting
the rook on the open open file towards
that pawn next to the black king very
very good very very very very well
Bates liquor into playing rook e8 here
which would defend the pawn a third time
and then maybe he'll see that he could
bring his King back to safety after
right I couldn't see that happening um
but it wouldn't but in general I mean I
think what's liquor has to do is just
make quick moves just try to make quick
moves and put a lot of pressure on the
clock position is very closed even
though he's got one work for a knight
there are a good chances here so I he
plays rook e8 good move rook f8 maybe
slightly preferable but it's it's a fine
move and really I guess the question is
here is how easy will it be for force
into a fine to plant and be find a plan
in timely manner where he doesn't use
too much Shawn right and what do you
think is the most straightforward but
also intuitive plan for him to continue
with here probably the most intuitive
plan would be to move the rooks he
didn't play Bishop d2 did he he did I
was gonna say Bishop e2 is the best move
but it's not intuitive at all so that's
that's a very nice move by forsen
because now the knight has to move and
now you can start to push the pawns in
the center I think once you get the
pawns going in the center it becomes
much more obvious in terms of what the
plans are for white so Bishop d2 is a
fantastic move by forsen and Queen h8 is
an interesting move by slicker I mean he
isn't protecting the g6 pawn anymore but
that one doesn't matter as much because
then maybe he'll get an attack by
opening up the King side and instead of
retreating his knight and allowing the
white pawns to come forward he would
bring in his Queen so actually I like
the way slickers replying I do too I
mean I think the question is will force
and take the knight and grab this pawn
on the g6 squared the light square pawn
I'd it's probably the best idea whether
it makes sense I'm not so sure but I do
I do expect it to to happen
so you do expect that he's going for
this he takes it right away and instead
which is the best move by the way forsen
is really oh is their trip with 9200 me
if you take though so I don't know if
you saw Alexander's but I actually had
this Anastasia Chuck made any game
against box box oh really
yeah he he thought I couldn't check meet
him in 20 moves or something I was 19
moves but yeah what I was gonna say is
it doesn't work here but if you show the
variation Knight to e2 yep I'll put it
on the board yeah Knight to e2 King to
h1 mm-hmm Queen takes h2 it doesn't
quite work but after Queen a zucchini a
shoe broke h8 on this is like the
Anastasia shucks me because the King
can't go over now in this case white can
prevent it but for a second I thought
there might be an incredible checkmate
resource for yeah that would have been
quicker so chat if there wasn't a queen
or a bishop then white would have had to
sacrifice but okay let me go back to the
current situation cuz 97 was played
Queen takes c6 and King d8 and now
Bishop to g5 would just finish the game
here because of the pin on the King in
the night they just be amazing like he
would like he would say that yeah yeah
he might see this the reason why it's
not so natural is because he's already
been moving the bishop back and forth
but I think now that he's attacking he
doesn't ooh ative Lee understand that if
he brings more pieces you know he's more
likely to finish off the game here well
I mean this is for us when we're talking
about I mean he's the he's oh that was
perfect timing he cards what were you
seeing
please continue with that side um well
he also has now a lesson three minutes
on the clock I mean he's still winning
here even with that right it's not such
a big deal but he traded off one pair of
rooks which does make you a little
nervous yeah this is now it's game on
again even though he's way ahead he's up
by three pawns this is uh yeah now it's
game on this is there's no guarantee
here the force and I mean I've seen
force and play some of these endgame
positions very very well but I'm okay
trades the Queen's right yeah I mean
he's still winning the game but he has
to be careful here about like tricks
like back rank checked me it's and all
kinds of other stuff like rook to e2
here could be a very tricky move
um Oh get don't get don't get back ring
Chuck made it yep
so he either has to hold the e1 square
with his Bishop obviously the best move
is Bishop g5 because then he checks
black and he can make space for his King
well rook b8 is probably actually the
best move just cuz you cleant you end up
in a rook and pawn anymore you can just
push the pawns down the board but
this is this is this is dicey there's
this is getting tricky with 2 minutes on
the clock let's listen to slicker I
think he is he's feeling more confident
now I can only work for time I can only
work for time like he's took all my
pawns the only thing is time
motivational music the promise flicker
doesn't do the technique that's the
problem
wait oh no no it's forcing certainty
here I freaked out for a second sorry he
did he defended against it
I should actually do not I'm so silly
but what
well now forsen has a lot of extra funds
I think this is not easy but very likely
conversion for him yeah I think at this
point it should be it should be pretty
pretty it should be pretty
straightforward I would say for um for
Forrest I think with the pawns
especially the three pawns that he has
on the other side of the board it should
not be very difficult to push him up and
I have seen force and used like two
pawns together so with the three pawns I
see no reason that he shouldn't be able
to just push him up the board it looks
looks pretty straightforward to me yeah
that's this very fair I mean he got rid
of the checkmate threat so now he
doesn't have to worry about that anymore
he does stuff a minute and 22 on the
clock you think this is enough time for
him I think based on where the pawns are
and it's a very obvious idea to push
them up the board I think forcings gonna
win this game pretty pretty cleanly here
yeah yeah and he seems so focused I love
how forces chain face has not been has
remained unchanged the entire match
right this is sure you guys literally
had it in the same stance in the same
it's just the same look for the whole
whole game I guess he is a real chess
player then yeah he's just been very
very impressive I mean he blundered the
rook that's one mistake he did he made
this very dramatic for like three moves
but mostly it's been it's been a lot of
a lot of good stuff from him
yeah and he is just having such a clean
finale here I imagine he might just
continue pushing his other pawns as well
and he knows he I mean even without
knowing and game basics which you
probably already does at this point he
can get so many extra pieces that
there's not much to worry about
yeah III I think forsen I would put it
again at like 95% chance he wins this
game meat oh yeah what is that
free pawn right pawn right but again
it's still fine because I mean he has to
pass pawns but it's not accurate it's
not accurate yeah I mean this is oh okay
there's yeah still a cellmate is now
what's liquor should be hoping for yeah
I don't think it's gonna happen now yeah
and now I know it's I think it's too
late but but even here you see like this
is kind of why I was saying forsen is
one of the favorites but there are
moments in the game where he just
temporarily like he just slips he like
tunnels he just sob stops focusing or
something and and something bad can
happen so he's gonna win this game
but that's probably the one thing I
would say is it like one or two moves he
always has this issue with the UH with
the UH with the position where he just
he kind of forgets or something
something happens but do you see that
happening more often when he's in a
better position that he slips up I think
he just happens in general as I said
most the players in the term and there's
like some spot where they just seem to
blunder a rook or a queen it just seems
to be one of those things that happens I
wouldn't say there's something specific
but it odd happens from time to time
yeah I was wondering because sometimes
when you're in a better position you're
a bit more relaxed and that's what he
wasn't now he probably doesn't think
there's any way he could lose so maybe
that's why for this situation but if
it's something you've seen throughout
then never mind okay the checkmate is
almost coming in here yeah he hadn't
made in one but it doesn't really matter
if he does it in the fastest way as long
as he finishes it off here he has so
many extra pieces right yeah at this
point I think it's
I think it's pretty clean although I
mean I guess what that pond
I mean the pond can always moved on c7
so I guess there's no real chance I was
seeing there's somebody to go like king
c6 or something and make a stalemate but
they're there this is no way here right
so king c6 cuz you're blocking the
movement of your own pond so then right
it's only your king that okay well he
goes to d4 so that doesn't actually
matter and the rook has now been lost as
well I'm hoping that forsen just makes a
checkmate a hint he doesn't do it he
doesn't pull in him here and like really
be nasty although I could see it so I
was playing on for longer than he needed
to did he expect his opponent to resign
no I mean he was a total beyond I mean
it was just for fun
just for fun yeah well slickers trying
to hide his King behind forsen spawns
here
all right well he still has that pond
he's very forsen is very lucky that he
doesn't have to worry at all right it's
no I think force is just gonna make the
Chuck man although he's kind of doing
this in a very weird weird manner of
speaking like the way he's putting the
Queen in the brook yeah and he does have
enough time to sit and think here
yeah I mean I I guess what I would say
at this point is you can actually you
know what you can see the little smile
on for some space now I think you try to
figure out does he wanna make a
checkmate or didn't see what does it
want to do it I think you can actually
see it on his face you can totally see
if horse is like smiling I mean he's
struggling between well let's listen to
slicker and see what he thinks of this
Gigi will plead it's disgusting the look
of it is just disgusting leave that
there but go ahead
Gigi up late mama it was Gigi Melissa Oh
for a second I mean at least it wasn't
too bad it was only two please I mean
Forsyth could have probably made like
four queens there but but still it's uh
it's still it's still pretty clean when
I think actually for scent the end II
had to make the checkmate so otherwise
there was real risk of it being a
stalemate right and yeah it seemed like
he just sounded easier to go promote
another Queen that's probably why he
smiled because he wasn't going for it
with a pieces he had already but I think
that was just to make it easier for him
himself with time pressure also yeah I
mean I think in general it was it was
pretty good
but but yeah I think you're right with
the two Queens he just realized he could
make the make the checks and it would be
easier if he had made fortrex you'd be
pulling the NIM but with only two Queens
I think it's completely reasonable well
the next match we're gonna see is
swifter versus Box locks but before that
we're gonna take a short break and we'll
be back with player interviews so stay
tuned chat and we are live were joined
by forsen and slicker and slicker you
were just telling forcing that he was he
got really lucky and opening here mean
look listen to this I I was born and
raised as a first person player right
first person skilled shooter game okay
he was born and raised as a 2-d player
so it makes a lot of sense the
comparison is relatable look hearthstone
and chess relatable you just to let you
know you know in hearthstone is
something called
oh by the way yo what's up pick up a
camera there was something in the
hearthstone that's called a tavern brawl
and in tavern brawl you can have like
chess so you play the pawns and all that
so this guy probably had no life
literally played it all day and I say
okay I'm silent silent I'm me right here
I don't know pro gamer any more games
that you play I've seen you play
counter-strike will you play a max
resolution you can't part to me you
can't you know I've heard people tell me
you got to LEM
oh you know how it's wintery people
watching stream alive oh my god is a
force that I'm gonna join win treat him
okay I solo went to legendary
kegelmaster you don't know and
teamliquid player what is called ina
best for I know I know let's just forget
about that like obviously I hit am a
global [__] the days this is a long
time I mean bro you got carried a mossy
games okay I'm not sure about other said
someone sit in my chair for some got be
said love EE his nation his csgo player
what is he talking about that's actually
true I do apologize for might be well
let's talk a little bit about what
happened here forced and maybe you can
start did you have this as preparation
or did you find it on the board the
Queen h5 maneuver no I've seen this move
in the what is it called it's called the
tracks are counter I think and then the
black counters with this situation where
you do this and he puts the pawn and
then you take it with the horse and if
it takes you did you get the
get the tower right right so I've seen
this before and I saw it in this
situation as well it's the horse was
perfectly placed so I went for it and
yeah now that was a really nice tactical
fine slicker did you get any help from
Hans coaching you for this game
absolutely absolutely not absolutely not
not this time
okay I don't want any coaching you see I
can't hands is just bad luck okay
that's my boy no shout out to my boy
hands but he's just bad luck okay look
at look what he done Tara but today I
see Rob's always but look look what he's
done to wait I say he's giving it only
to me in him well no I didn't want any
coaching okay it seemed like he komaru
ditched me hosted forsen and he was
basically saying that for soon was going
to win explain not now explain that mr.
Costa the whole thing was an hour
earlier or I would have helped you but
but you had your chances though to be
fair
did you realize that you had this one
moment late in the game where you almost
have this checkmate you only you told
you're lying I check this admit miss
wins right people because there was one
point if you go back right here if you
yeah you see the position right off this
Bishop move with the check LEM
so which will club yeah just what in the
zoom you should see the board all right
yeah I'm blood here you could have moved
the King over one square to attack the
rook right and there's only one move
here for white that is good which is to
bring the rook all the way back
if white see Texas pawn here like if
white moves the reformer you go rip down
and it's checkmate oh my god Ilana how
did I not notice that it's so is so
winning if white brings the rook all the
way back but it did there was this one
moment where you were really really
close worse than what I've seen it
regardless I was very focused on not
letting him get the checkmate when I was
ahead that's why I I was actually
thinking about with the tower up and
shaking him taking the horse and then
letting him have the bishop so I was up
in material at one point but I
try to be fancy somehow you know what I
I will admit I am the lose in this game
well you know what I think that's a
compliment you know obviously that's a
compliment I'm also in place to me I'm
so good at every game I won't go that
far or go that far okay listen hearts
don't stick to hostile okay listen stick
to play major whatever the other
champions are that's you're just too D&E
that's what you are for skin
I mean forsen I don't know how old you
Wow shocking dice absolutely no I just
turned 22 yesterday 22 then why are you
so [__] bad at games when you have
sumer reactions I don't get it what's
your disguise Mon look he's talking look
at the timer go casters please shows the
time how long you took in each me oh
yeah forgot I brought in my vocabulary I
don't have Bhima no semen no kuma okay I
don't talk like that boy I mean Zuma
means fast right boys game look there's
a timer okay let me give you an example
in hearthstone there's a timer it goes
every time when you move an opponent you
wait and you wait it to the last minute
when time is ticking remember when she
says that and that's when you move me
and Jess you have time you take all your
sufficient time to find out what to do
next
I don't know I got no time after that
saref Optimas waiting outside ain't got
time for that
I clearly well I'm really loving this is
back and forth of banter here I mean
slicker if you got a rematch against
forsen you know maybe a friendly rematch
what do you think would happen I will
fall asleep
I mean look listen the guy takes too
long he like NIM too boring us long
displays okay I don't want to play games
because I'm so surprised that you're
opening when you're building so if you
wanted me to try what it took five
minutes each ten all the three minutes
specifically each movement okay and then
you would have seen I'm su the shocking
amazing a place you see me rush fast
right oh you're gonna die I'm gonna do
okay so I could do that
let me get he said no hello yes I lost
money I just lost I let everyone down
mother to be honest no one's gonna win
[Music]
today up against nerds I mean no offense
like you are up against like who who's
gonna be a boy boy yes yes ooh box horse
you know Papa Lottie me I'm against
Europe easy with xqc oh please blindfold
me right now I play against him easy win
who else is gonna be choco-balls
hesitation not required easy win so I'm
glad you went through congratulations
for us and I'm happy honestly all my
life you and them good look when you go
into the Champions League but look
companies League this ain't no football
but good luck when you go into the
Champions final main honestly yeah yeah
it was a good game no mom it was close
at least I got to the point where I see
my kingdom
instantly checkmate you know I tried
well um
slicker I will say that Hans was in the
chat saying he believes in you so you
threw him out as your coach and you know
what he did he came back to watch you
play and let chat know that he was
rooting for you well let him know that
he it's my boy yo handz yo my boy man I
ain't gonna diss you but listen you just
talk too much that's it I do apologize
when you just talk too much and uh you
come in you come in this is what it was
okay he comes he says oh hey tomorrow's
him you up I'm gonna leave are you
serious I will just play talking and
then there's all the time like yo
my view counts going down can you help
me like is your real friend guys right
that's I'm talking about I don't know if
it hands is my boy anyway listen doesn't
my okay shout out to my boy hands shout
to everyone hey no shell take amaru boat
as you know forcing well played thank
you for the the game it was for my
lesson I'm in the brackets now well of
forces so you're gonna be playing NIM
three days from now
any words on how you're preparing for it
or how you think it'll go you don't need
to prepare for he's really gonna go
until it's gonna last literally ten
minutes wait 20 minutes 10 minutes name
ten minutes forcing never ending it's
just never gonna end the book just gonna
try too hard
hey listen I'm gonna be real uh you know
if you guys don't want my opinion he's
gonna win but you know I might as well
just tell you but I really do think you
I talk too much I'm done no I'll give it
to someone else I'm talking too much I
do apologize for my inconvenience well
who do you think is gonna win slicker
between force and in him thank you for
asking I would say it was good I'd
probably go for name I got no beef we
got no beef you know I ain't got no beef
with you I know you made NIM okay boy
I'm I'd seen him probably in the please
all right he does I swear he does play
he's a good sees a smart guy well
fortunately you honestly played an
incredible game today he car was really
impressed and I been doing commentary
with him for a while now and I haven't
seen that happen very often so actually
real congratulations for that very very
good very good
Congrats yeah and it's liquor I mean you
had that opening trap but other than
that you did try to fight pretty well so
good luck in your game versus choco bar
slicker force it having you guys on the
call take care
they